he's entering his fourth year in the
national football league third round
pick in the 2018 draft and he signed a
four-year 56 million dollar contract
extension on his 26th birthday
happy birthday to you baltimore ravens
tight end mark andrews how are you mark
hey rich thanks for having me on um you
know like you said it was an incredibly
good birthday um couldn't have asked for
anything more man i'm incredibly blessed
yeah i mean if somebody told you growing
up hey on your 26th birthday you're
going to sign a for your 56 million
dollar extension with an nfl franchise
what would you said
uh man i would have thought you're crazy
man but uh i've been working a long time
for this a lot of hard work that has
been put into this and um you know
sports have been my whole life so
you know just to be able to have that to
be able to do that my birthday with the
ravens
um you really can't ask for anything
more man this is an incredible place
a place where they love football they
love winning
and that's what i'm all about if i told
you on draft night that you would sign a
contract multi-million dollar contract
extension before baker mayfield your
college teammate what would you have
said on that night
oh man um i probably would have said
you're crazy again man again man there's
been a lot of hard work um you know
there's been a lot of people that um you
know throughout my career doubted me and
and whatnot so um just to be able to
have this contract and and stuff like
that it's awesome man so um obviously
being able to to one up guys like like
bake and and orlando um you know it's
good for me mark andrews here on the
rich eisen show on the mercedes-benz
vans phone line here uh on the friday of
the nfl season kicking off prior to the
monday night game between his ravens and
the raiders so did you watch do you
watch the season opener did you check
that one out yeah i did you did i i kind
of tuned out around the third quarter
but i was able to watch both teams
looked really really good
grog looked really really good so that
was fun to see
um but you know a lot of competition but
it feels awesome man having the nfl
season back and
obviously you got to watch the opener
and see how things go but um you know
football's back man so yeah i'm just
wondering how do you watch a game like
that as a player in the nfl what do you
what do you look at
i mean you know for me it's you know i i
try to it's hard to watch you know the
games on tv just because you watch film
and stuff like that so
i kind of approach it the same way i
watch them you know i watch the tight
ends um and then i watch the defense see
what they're doing so what do you see
when you see gronk what do you think of
when you see um he looks really really
good he's doing a lot of good things you
could tell that you know him and um
brady have been doing this for a long
long time um they look like they're in
mid season four
and you you know do you
uh aspire or think you've reached there
and you could just shoot me straight the
the elite status of tight ends i mean
you've got a contract like one you
definitely have numbers like one we talk
in the media quite a bit about gronk
another 87 in kansas city um also kittle
waller gets a lot of run do you feel
like you get enough run
you know i think when you think about a
guy like gronk uh yeah he's in a whole
another you know level you know in and
of itself and there may be a couple guys
with him but um you know he's he's a guy
that you got to hold up at the highest
pedestal he may be the top of that mount
rushmore
um you know just him being able to to
win yeah i think it's been four super
bowls now um you know that speaks uh you
know you know volumes so
um you know i do you know have a lot of
confidence in my skills and and
you know i think i'm at the highest
level an elite level
at the game right now and i can compete
with all those guys
but a guy like him you got to give him
his respect you know all right mark
andrews let's talk about what happened
in practice on thursday we all heard
about it and it just blew my mind just
as a fan
uh that gus edwards and marcus peters
both out
with um season-ending knee injuries that
we're all um expecting here what um
what can you tell me about practice walk
me through where you were what happened
in practice yeah both of them i think
for marcus is one it was towards the end
just like gus's but uh um you know it
happened um everyone saw it and kind of
you know everyone kind of you know went
quiet and stuff like that it was one of
those freak accidents and then
i think it was a play later two plays
later we flipped around um
and then you see gus go down i was
actually on the field for that one and
same thing a freak accident man so you
know it's
it's one of those things where you don't
expect that to happen it's it's part of
the game but
kind of a back to back same practice and
the stuff that we've been through all
off season
um it just sucks man but at the same
time you just got to pray for those guys
um keep their heads up and then keep our
heads up man we got a great team a
really deep team
that's what baltimore is all about
bringing a lot of great players in
that can play football so um you know to
count us out and you know that's all
right but we're going to be hungry and
ready to go well obviously this comes on
the heels of jk dobbins also being out
for the season how how does that
potentially shake your team i know you
say you're you want to you know uh use
this potentially as
um a stepping uh i guess a way for you
to move forward
but
just in the moment how do you as a team
handle something like this
yeah you know it you know jk again it's
it's tough but you know um as a team um
and and again as a running back group we
still have a lot of great guys you know
um tyson is going to do going to do his
thing man he's balled out all preseason
we got a lot of confidence in uh we got
a lot of confidence in the rest of the
guys in that group in in this offense
and in lamar
um and so you know there's not a lot of
confidence lost in this team you know
i'm saying so um we're gonna be ready to
go uh you know our hair is gonna be on
fire um monday night ready to play the
las vegas raiders man that's what it's
all about did the coach gather everyone
around did somebody in the locker room
talk about it or you just all just
you know uh have your quiet
conversations and and then uh strap on
the chin strap and go yep so uh you know
on the field kind of just said her
prayer ended practice just a couple
plays early um you know said that prayer
and then today
we had a little meeting team meeting and
just talking about you know what's going
on
obviously
we're all extremely sad for those guys
like i said and that was reiterated
but again uh we're in a fighting mood
and that's kind of what you know
harbaugh you know relayed to us is that
um you know we're
we're you know not backs up against the
wall but we're in a fighting mode you
know people are counting us out you know
people are saying this and that you know
we're having these injuries but um you
know we got to be ready to go we got a
great team we got a lot of great players
and we got a lot of fighters on this
team so that's what it's about for us
mark andrews few minutes left here with
the baltimore ravens pro bowl tight end
fresh with a new four-year contract
extension right here on the rich eisen
show so what about the passing game can
you tell us um how dynamic can it be
this has been something that's been
under the microscope microscope about
stretching the field putting points on
the board fast if you need to as opposed
to the the grind it out
method that your team is so famous for
to protect a lead what can you tell us
about that mark yeah yeah i think we've
done a great job of of one we gotta uh
we brought in you know two really good
um you know coaches in the receiving
receiving game and
that are going to really complement giro
and what he's able to do um you know
we've worked really hard this offseason
and otas and training camp and throwing
the ball and you know we've we've really
been clicking so i think it's going to
be dynamic i know it's going to be
dynamic and
you know i'm excited to go out there
monday night against the raiders be able
to show the show the world we can do
throw the ball around um let eight do
his thing and and and all his you know
supporting cash just just help him out
as much as we can what's your favorite
eight play that you give me your
favorite eight play that you mentioned
eight lamar jackson yeah um i think for
me was probably um i think it was my
rookie year um chargers the first time
we played them in in the charger stadium
ran a line route kind of right across
the field lamar threw a perfect ball
um right in stride and was able to score
like a 60-yard touchdown i love that you
chose a passing play i think i'm certain
no i'm serious because again it's
remarkable god was an mvp um and still
it's the same guy
uh but it's usually the play like say
him running one in against the titans
last year in a playoff game that was so
crucial for you and the team time and
time again man but again i mean the pass
was to me so it helps out
there is no eye in mark and andrews a
little bit they just heard one come out
right there
so uh with you taking on the las vegas
raiders on monday night football on
westwood one radio um what's the biggest
challenge this raiders defense presents
it's a new defensive coordinator in in
gus
bradley what do you what do you expect
to see from them right yeah
you know i know that you know they're
going to play hard they're going to be
physical they're going to run to the
ball um all those things that great
defenses do
um and and you know they they kind of
have that you know seattle 3 system so
we're going to be you know obviously
expecting that looking at that and
their front seven or front eight really
is is really really good and then um
being able to detect their secondary uh
which is which is gonna be um obviously
they play a lot of zones so being able
to see that and be able to fit in those
zones is what we're looking for okay and
then you know you'll have to have your
head on a swivel there it's the first
time with fans there's a nightclub i
guess there's all sorts of bells and
whistles in that stadium
i don't know
i don't know if you did they set up like
a nightclub at practice to sort of
simulate what you're gonna have to deal
with and the game conditions right no no
gloves man but again that's exciting man
to be able to play the first game in
that stadium
i know that place is going to be rocking
you know as a football player that's
kind of what you live for
on the road everyone's booing
you know against you when you're on
offense um and be able to quiet that
down um so that's exciting for us man
that's what i look for and i know this
team you know kind of thrives in that
situation sort of uncork your own bottle
service no doubt right is what you're
saying we'll do it after the game yeah
little ravens on the rocks is what
you're saying straight up raven's on the
rocks that's right i like that
okay very good hey mark andrews thank
you for the time greatly appreciate it
congrats on your gig and your and your
deal um let's do this more often i
appreciate it rich it was great talking
with you right back at you that's mark
andrews getting set for monday night
football against the
las vegas raiders right here on the rich
eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here